blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman hey everybody i'm farin cousins
in for david pakman and this
is the david pakman show
we've got all kinds of great stuff
coming up today the latest on
afghanistan of course some covet updates
for you and even a little bit of insight
into what is happening with republican
congressman matt gates and that
investigation and
some other problems that he's having
right here where i'm sitting in
florida's first congressional district
but let's kick things off obviously
still the biggest news in the world
right now
afghanistan
things uh getting worse of course
and here's something interesting that's
happened
and this was actually pointed out by
dave weigel
of the washington post where weigel
pointed out over the weekend
that a web page on the rnc's official
website seems to have disappeared
and that website or web page i guess
was the page talking about donald
trump's historic peace deal as they
called it
with the taliban with regards to
afghanistan
if you go to that page now there's just
a 404 page not found error
because apparently the republican
national committee doesn't want people
seeing that they're promoting that
ridiculous peace deal that donald trump
allegedly worked out and there's a
couple reasons for that too so let's
dive right into those first and foremost
they don't want any attention
on what donald trump did as president
with regard to afghanistan and let's be
honest there's a lot
but the peace deal that he allegedly had
worked out with the taliban that was
signed in february of 2020
is the biggest thing they don't want
people to remember
and that's because once you dig down
into the details of this so-called peace
deal you realize how horrible it
actually was and the biggest
problem with this peace deal
is that it completely excluded
the afghan government
no leaders from afghanistan were
involved in the drafting of this
and the protections that the united
states agreed to with the taliban
did not extend
to the actual afghanistan
government
the deal only pertained
to u.s troops
and our nato allies in the country that
the taliban
would not attack them in exchange for
the united states agreeing to leave the
country within 14 months
but nowhere
not any part of that agreement did the
taliban say oh by the way we we won't
promise
to not attack the afghanistan government
apparently that was just a major
oversight
of this peace deal
and of course
as soon as the united states leaves
the taliban goes and overthrows the
government of afghanistan
so yeah it's not surprising that they
would want that web page removed from
existence
because they're boasting about it
talking about look what donald trump did
bringing peace to the middle east with
this historic deal
nope
nope another total failure by donald
trump
another reason though that they do not
want this page out there in existence
and i think this is probably the bigger
one
is because they want all the focus right
now
to be on joe biden
that is the goal
make this biden's failure
make this all about his decision
to remove trump's from afghan troops
from afghanistan ignoring the fact that
even just a couple months ago donald
trump was you know screaming at the top
of his lungs
to tell joe biden to get the troops out
of afghanistan
but they have to frame this as biden's
failure because that's the new talking
point
it emerged fast it emerged quick and
based on what we're seeing in the media
tends to be the uh sticking narrative at
this point that this is all joe biden's
fault
and let's obviously be clear about this
that's not the case
this is the fault of four different
administrations
but if you had to lay the blame at
anybody's feet that blame is going to be
squarely at the feet of george w bush
and i will get more into that in just a
little bit but the talking point from
the rnc
from republican officials
from elected officials from donald trump
himself is all about joe biden being a
catastrophic failure
and they're hoping that they can ride
this all the way through the midterms
you know i pointed out yesterday on the
program
that the republicans have had a hell of
a time getting any kind of talking point
to stick about joe biden
they have crafted all these narratives
fox news has tested them out and even
fox news at one point was getting
frustrated because nothing they were
saying or using to attack biden was
resonating with the audience
well this is something that would
resonate
and again as i mentioned fair or not
biden was the president when this
happened so if people are going to blame
somebody they are going to blame him
i don't agree with that assessment at
all
but i also live in reality i've been
doing this long enough you know coming
up on two decades at this point we know
how these things play out
we know where the blame is going to go
and we know the talking points that the
republicans are going to use
and one of the main reasons we know that
is because we're literally already
seeing it happen
on social media in the corporate media
republicans are pushing this non-stop
and they want to keep it that way
they want the focus
to remain on joe biden because that's
the message joe biden couldn't keep
afghanistan safe and if he can't keep
them safe how's he going to keep you
safe
we're already
starting to see the narrative crop up
of oh what is taliban taking over
afghanistan mean for terror attacks here
in the united states
several outlets started reporting
stories like that on monday
they're already
trying to pose this as what is the
significant threat that this will pose
to us here in the united states can
biden even keep us safe now
we're right back into that same post 911
mentality
where every time you turn around there's
a boogie man being pushed on you
by these politicians who are using it
to scare you into submission to scare
you into voting for them
and that's what we're starting to see
now it's disgusting but again it's 100
percent predictable
this is how they operate this is the way
they craft their narrative this is the
way they sell it to the public
and unfortunately the republican party
is very very good at selling these
narratives in a way that the democratic
party can only ever dream of being
on issue after issue republicans get out
front on the messaging and that is what
sticks and then the democrats have to
come from behind trying to defend it
debunk it refute it whatever it and
they're never on the offensive and this
narrative has already been lost
it's already been lost
so again whether you agree with biden's
decision to pull the troops out i do
whether you disagree with it doesn't
matter
the narrative that the media has already
captured is that this is a failure of
the biden administration and republicans
are going to ride that all the way
to the 2022
midterms
but as i mentioned
if you want to lay the blame for the
failures in afghanistan at anybody's
feet
it has to be at the feet of george w
bush
and right now
both biden and twice impeached former
president donald trump
seem to want to lay the blame at each
other's feet
you've got members of the biden
administration coming out and saying no
everything that's happening right now is
donald trump's fault
and then trump of course is issuing his
idiotic statement saying look at all
these failures of biden i left him a
road map and he didn't follow it this is
his fault
these two going back and forth and back
and forth completely ignoring
that this all started under george w
bush folks and i know i've said this
plenty of times i've already said it
today it's gone through four
administrations at this point
but
george w bush's name was not mentioned
once
on the sunday talk shows this past
weekend not once
you cannot talk about afghanistan
without talking about george w bush and
the failures of the war on terror the
failures of this uh nation building that
we went on over there
that's where all the failures began
and yes it is accurate to say that both
democrat and republican administrations
came along after that and continued this
disastrous policy
but they weren't the ones who
implemented it everyone who has
inherited this afghanistan mess since
george w bush left office hasn't had a
road map they haven't known what the
heck to do over there
so we keep momming we keep sending
weapons
we keep the killing going we keep the
troops over there maybe we're going to
bring him home maybe we're not
you know that happened during obama
and then instead oh no we're going to
send more
happened under trump we're going to
bring him home no wait we got it we got
to we got to send a few more we're going
to put more military contractors over
there we're going to bring troops back
some of them but we're going to double
down on the number of military
contractors we have over there that also
happened by the way earlier this year
with the biden administration because
nobody has known
what to do
because there was never any real goal
the so-called war on terror was such a
vague concept
that it could mean anything
and we went into it
obviously with a lot of hostility
following 911
we were not thinking clearly as a nation
we wanted revenge we wanted retribution
and of course because
george w bush had all these you know
former officials from the first gulf war
in his administration they wanted to go
back over there and finish the job
so they focused on iraq they kept
afghanistan over there on the back
burner we got to do taliban yeah yeah
we're going to get them but iraq was the
big prize
so afghanistan fell by the wayside we
still kept troops there we still kept
fighting there
but never really had a plan there that
was kind of just the for show part oh
we're looking for bin laden over in
afghanistan that's that's what we're
doing over there but hey we just got
saddam hussein right and that's that's
what everybody wanted
following 911 as corey robin pointed out
on twitter the other day
90 of the american public supported
uh sending troops to afghanistan
so when i say we weren't thinking
clearly as a nation that's the kind of
thing i'm talking about here 90 of
people supported this thing
not knowing what it was really about not
knowing what was going on but george
bush and his administration lied us over
there
and got us stuck
and then they left and obama continued
then he left
and trump continued now we've got biden
pulling troops out
trump saying oh look at what an idiot
you are again ignoring the fact that
just a few months ago he was begging
biden to finish what he started pulling
all the troops out
at this point
it wouldn't have mattered if we had
pulled troops out of there in 2004 or
2010 or 2020 or even 2030
this would have happened
this same thing that we're watching
unfold right now with the taliban
capturing kabul this still would have
happened
because there was no goal
there was no strategy
there was no actual peace deal
negotiated between the u.s government
and the taliban and the afghani
government
and this is what we got
this is the disaster
that we have to deal with now
and again i don't think anybody really
knows what to do about this
do we just let the taliban take over
walk away and say well good luck you got
a mess on your hands
i i don't agree with sending troops back
over there i think it's just another
disaster you're just prolonging this
from happening again
and nobody knows the answer
the answer though is that we have to
continue to help the people of
afghanistan
we need to be able to get them out of
the country
we need to take in as many refugees as
we possibly can here in the united
states i don't want to hear anger from
conservatives about this we put them in
this situation we've got to take care of
them
and that's the best thing we can do
right now
i am farren cousins from ring of fire
more of me you can get it at ring of
fire or excuse me youtube.com slash the
ring of fire i'm sitting in for david
pakman today we'll be right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousin sitting in for david
pakman today you can find me on social
media on both twitter facebook and of
course instagram as well
at
balanced you can get me on youtube
youtube.com the ring of fire and
youtube.com slash
farron balanced
we've got more to talk about with
afghanistan and you know not to be
outdone from all of the stupid takes
going on out there about afghanistan
marjorie taylor greene
comes out
with one of the most absurd and quite
possibly disgusting
takes on what is happening in the
country and without further ado folks
i am going to let marjory taylor green
say it in her own words here she is an
interview from sunday with steve bannon
take it away congressman marjorie
taylor-green uh you've heard what
president trump says do you agree with
that given your assessments a pretty big
that's a pretty big ask for a president
to resign
about something like this do you agree
with that
absolutely as a matter of fact i have my
team uh right now working on articles of
impeachment because i'm so disgusted
with joe biden you know i've already
filed one set of articles of impeachment
but but his
failure as a president is is unspeakable
there's reporting that the u.s is paying
a vast sum of cash to the taliban in
exchange for allowing the evacuation to
proceed
is this true
now she can't verify that i know what's
going around um
give us your thoughts on that even the
mention of that is pretty stunning what
are your thoughts on this and what are
you hearing
i i can't verify that either so i won't
say if it's true or not unless i had
direct proof of it but i would not doubt
it look at the way president biden has
the american military basically running
scared out of afghanistan and they were
begging the taliban to give them time
and wait until they could evacuate from
the airport and so i'm i wouldn't be
surprised at all if they were paying the
taliban after all they're already paying
them with weapons vehicles blackhawk
helicopters because the afghan army army
is handing them over as fast as possible
wouldn't be surprised to learn
even though
as bannon mentioned yeah i mean there's
no evidence of this marjorie taylor
green says yeah i mean there's no
evidence of it but let's pretend there
is and say oh i bet it's happening
that's that's that's how republican lies
grow i hope you realize what we just
witnessed there folks
that was the birth
of a talking point
it's a stupid talking point
again there's no evidence to suggest
that that's what's happening but why
should that stop them
from just making stuff up
about what's really taking place and by
the way
a little part of that clip in the in the
in the full clip um
if anybody wants to go and watch it it's
it's terrible but bannon actually
mentioned he got those questions
from republican congresswoman elise
stefanik's office
so yeah just to let you know like how
staged all this crap really is
stefanik's office sent those questions
over to him
i guess in an attempt to get marjorie
taylor green to say something stupid
which of course she never disappoints
with that
in case you're wondering
what's really happening right now is yes
the united states has in fact worked out
a deal with the taliban
to where they will not
attack the airport in kabul so that they
can continue to get refugees out of the
country
i'm sure by now most people have seen
some of the footage
of the people desperate to flee the
country literally climbing on top of
airplanes um i i believe at least uh
half a dozen or more people have been
killed
literally being run over by airplanes on
the runway to the point where on monday
they actually had to call it off they
couldn't have any more flights because
the airport was being flooded with
people trying to leave the country so
the administration came out had to try
to work out this deal
which they discussed over in i believe
is dohar
so they worked out this deal and said
listen you have to let us get people out
of here you have to let us get these
refugees you have to promise to not
attack this airport otherwise they said
the general who you know helped work out
this deal if you attack the airport
you're going to be met with you know the
swift fury
of the united states military so let us
get people out
and we will not attack you
there was no indication that money
changed hands there was no
obvious as she pointed out uh exchange
of weapons
and i believe
if i may try to make sense of what
marjorie taylor green is saying the
fact that she's talking about oh we're
giving them weapons no we're not
let's be clear about that as far as i've
seen and feel free to correct me if i'm
wrong but i don't know that the united
states has made a deal to give the
taliban weapons
what we have seen
is that they have raided
the afghan military's weaponry which yes
is full of weapons that the united
states gave them
so i guess if you want to consider that
the united states giving weapons to
these individuals then you know it's a
roundabout way of saying it it's
obviously not exactly true but
technically sure i mean well i guess i
guess you could say that the united
states gave them weapons
because we gave it to these people who
then abandoned it and it was taken over
by the taliban
so
maybe we need to stop giving all these
weapons to people overseas i don't know
that sounds like a pretty easy solution
heck we could probably cut down the
military budget the pentagon budget
every year if we didn't do that so you
actually accidentally just made a really
great case marjorie taylor green
for not continuing to send united states
weapons
overseas
i i think that's a good plan and if
that's where you really want to go
marjorie i'm i'm with you 100
i would love to see the united states no
longer sending our weapons of death
all over the planet
as i'm sure a lot of people on the left
would agree with me on that
but again
it is just remarkable to see them
you know in the early stages of a new
talking point like biden's paying them
off there's no evidence to suggest it
but we probably think that it's
something that could likely maybe happen
you know it's not impossible it's a
plausible idea so let's just push it
and see if the public
buys into that narrative
that's how they operate they don't have
to have facts
they don't have to have evidence
when you're a republican talking head or
a republican politician whatever you can
make up
is what sticks
and that becomes the narrative
that they run with
and speaking of horrible narratives um
donald trump has been out there over the
last few days
scribbling down his little idiotic you
know statements as fast as he can having
his spokeswoman liz harrington uh tweet
them out
and of course most of them have been
about afghanistan you know trying to lay
all of this squarely at the feet of joe
biden but in one of his statements which
i'm about to read
he actually said something else he
blamed biden
for another surrender not just allegedly
surrendering to the taliban here it is
first joe biden surrendered to covid and
it's come roaring back
then he surrendered to the taliban who
has quickly overtaken afghanistan and
destroyed confidence in american power
and influence the outcome in afghanistan
including the withdrawal would have been
totally different if the trump
administration had been in charge who or
what will joe biden surrender to next
someone should ask him if they can find
him
yeah says the guy that spent like 25
of his presidency not at the white house
if they can find him
oh we know where to find you golf dude
you're probably hitting the link
somewhere right actually you're probably
sitting in a dark room just scribbling
these things out as fast as you can like
let's get this out
now
i've addressed the afghanistan stuff but
surrendering to covid
that's just plain idiotic
now don't get me wrong
i have not been shy
about criticizing the biden
administration when they deserve to be
criticized
it's what i do and i'm not going to stop
doing that
but their response to covid
no i'm sorry
that's not something that i've
criticized
because they've done a pretty dang good
job have they been perfect no
there's a couple of things they've done
or said that i've disagreed with
for example you know when they first
came out said we're going to get all the
kids back in school yeah i thought at
the time you know what it's a little too
soon and hey of course look where we're
at now
but to say he surrendered to covid
this coming from the guy that once told
people to inject bleach
coming from the same guy who said we'd
have zero cases
by april 2020 that we would be reopened
by easter of 2020 the guy who downplayed
the pandemic every possible chance he
got accusing another person of
surrendering to the virus
that's just plain nuts
and here's the thing yeah we got a surge
of covet in this country
but in no way is that joe biden's fault
no way at all i'm sorry but it's not
the fault right now
lies with the anti-massacres
it lies with the anti-vaxxers
and of course it lies with any governor
regardless of party that is not allowing
their cities or school districts to
implement mass mandates
and actually all of those republicans
happen to be
or excuse me all those governors happen
to be republicans
so that's actually where we're at right
now
the only people in this country that
have surrendered to kovid
are those republican leaders who
continue to surrender
to the nuttiest people in their states
the most misinformed people in their
states
we have seen polls show that a majority
of americans support mass mandates
furthermore polls have also shown that a
majority of americans would be okay with
vaccine passports and vaccine
mandates
even people who aren't vaccinated
support
vaccine passports
so we know there is not a ton of
disagreement about the fact that we need
to take care of each other
but that hasn't stopped these republican
governors
people like ron desantis greg abbott asa
hutchinson all of them
have banned mass mandates in their
states and now we're also seeing massive
coveted surges in the republican
controlled state of mississippi under
republican governor tate reeve
reeves who came out the other day
and actually said that coveting kids is
basically just the sniffles
less than 24 hours later an 8th grader
in mississippi
died of covid
nobody has surrendered to covid except
for the republicans
the biden administration has done a
great job here in the united states of
getting vaccines out there they have
done a great job of coming in and taking
care of these red states
after they've had to admit oh no we
can't handle it
you know sending 300 more ventilators
down here to the state of florida
because our hospitals are overwhelmed
over in i think it's texas they're you
know
building these new covered beds
in a parking garage
mississippi hospitals filling up alabama
hospitals filling up georgia hospitals
filling up
and of course texas and florida seeing
it too
and biden's been there every step of the
way
biden has been supportive
of the school districts and counties
that are defying these republican
governors and putting mass mandates in
place
all that's left for biden to do at this
point is make a nationwide mass mandate
which by the way he already did for uh
federally funded forms of public
transportation
he has not surrendered to covid in the
least
the republicans have their idiotic
policies followed with their idiotic
talking points casting doubt about the
effectiveness of the vaccine casting
doubt about the effectiveness
of masks
that
is what is fueling the coveted surge in
the united states today and none of that
is the fault of joe biden that fault
rests on the shoulders of the
republicans who have decided to
politicize this pandemic
that is what is going on in the united
states today and trump absolutely has
just infuriated me
trying to suggest otherwise
i am farron cousins i'm sitting in for
david pakman we've got a lot more
wonderful stories coming up and don't
forget follow me on all my social media
accounts at fahren balanced we'll be
right back with more
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today if you want
more from me you can find me on youtube
on my two channels youtube.com the ring
of fire and youtube.com
fair and balanced i'm also on twitter
facebook and instagram
at fair and balanced on all three
accounts easy enough to find right
let's get right back into some of
today's top stories uh one of the ones
that i definitely have to talk about
here mostly because
look i'm sitting in florida's first
congressional district my congressman is
matt gates one of the most embarrassing
members of congress out there
and matt gates having a tough go of it
recently
obviously embroiled in this potential uh
you know underage sex trafficking
scandal still under investigation for
that now last week of course
and i believe uh jesse dolemore who was
filling in for pacman uh talked about
this a little so i'm only going to hit
on this part briefly but yes last week
we found out that joel greenberg the
former seminole county tax collector has
been cooperating with federal
authorities giving them thousands of
pages
that includes pictures and of course
there's some videos mixed in there as
well
uh text messages private conversations
all kinds of information some of it that
does appear to directly implicate matt
gates in this scandal
so that's really bad for him
but even that aside let's assume for a
moment that matt gates wasn't under
investigation and matt gates was still
going about doing his matt gates stuff
believe it or not here in florida's very
red first congressional district
things are not all rosy for matt gates
in fact republicans in this district are
growing tired of his antics
they're getting tired of the fact
that the guy as one republican put it
actually a republican who plans the
primary gates says
he's everywhere but here
matt gates is neglecting
his district
and one former party chair from this
area
expressed his concern
saying that we need somebody that
actually cares we need somebody that
comes back matt gates has not held an
event in this district
since march
so here we are
you know over five months later
and matt gates has been out to
california
he's been in the midwest he's been in
the southeast or southwest
he's been in south florida
he's been everywhere but here as they
say
he doesn't want to come home
now don't get me wrong matt gates still
enjoys a lot of support in this district
and barring any indictments against him
he's going to win re-election
that is a given
the point is there's cracks in the
facade
just a few cracks at this point
but those cracks are growing and the
republicans here republicans with a
voice
are starting to get annoyed by the fact
that he is neglecting this
district
we had last year hurricane sally come
through here
sally
knocked out
a bridge that was the main artery for
traffic between two cities actually my
city right here
and
where my actual ring of fire studio is
so we had to drive an hour out of the
way because that bridge was gone all of
those businesses on either end of that
bridge
ended up closing down some permanently
some temporarily that bridge which was
knocked out i believe last september is
when the storm came through was only
reopened
the last week of may of this year
millions of dollars in economic revenue
lost because
the bridge got knocked down
we had republican state leaders coming
here all the time
talking about it trying to hold the
company skanska accountable because they
actually had left their barges not tied
up when the hurricane came through and
those bargers are what got swept into
the bridge and knocked it down so those
republicans came here
acted like they
cared matt gates was nowhere to be seen
his district was literally in crisis
following a hurricane dude didn't care
wasn't out here demanding justice wasn't
out here trying to fight skanska for
their neglect over there nothing
just going on fox news as frequently as
possible which he's not even welcome
there anymore
because that's what matt gates wants to
do
and that's what people in this district
need to
understand i firmly believe
that matt gates's end goal
is not to
be president of the united states
heck it's not even to be a senator he
doesn't care as much about political
power what he cares about
is fame and popularity
that is why obviously earlier this year
we had all those reports of matt gates
reaching out to network saying hey would
you hire me as a as a pundit would you
hire me as a talking head can i have a
show
that's why two weeks ago he launched his
new podcast video podcast
firebrand with matt gates
that's what the guy wants to do he wants
this
and matt buddy let me tell you man
if this is what you want
resign
or simply don't run for re-election just
let the clock run out and go and be the
bestest republican talking head you can
be
get yourself a camera we already know
you built a studio in your dad's house
use that studio
put your videos on youtube i'm sure you
would gain millions of subscribers in a
matter of weeks you'd make a ton of
money having that many people follow you
you could sell subscriptions you could
get advertisers you could do whatever
the heck you wanted you would have more
money in fame than you could ever
imagine and after all isn't that what
you want
but instead in order to get to that
point
you're taking up a congressional seat
you're literally getting nothing done in
washington dc you're traveling the
country with one of the most despised
members of congress out there marjorie
taylor green you're an embarrassment to
this district and the entire state of
florida and you're doing it all so you
can build up your brand
so that you can hopefully sell it when
you leave
office if of course you're not sitting
in a jail cell
by the time it all comes crashing down
that's the problem that matt gates faces
but don't worry folks this district is
safe for republicans and i think that's
why they're not putting up that much of
a stink right now
if they thought they had a democrat that
could come along and win this district
they would absolutely be encouraging
gates to step down get replaced by a
different republican so that they could
put all their eggs in that basket
but they know that whatever happens to
gates a republican will come behind him
and win the seat regardless or gates
himself will continue to win it
that's why they're not worried
but you know who should be worried right
now
the democratic party
a recent report by nbc news
says that by all indicators
the democrats are basically poised for a
midterm shellacking
in 2022
now
before we even get into any of these
indicators let's talk about history
right
and this is something that i'm sure
david's talked about i know i've talked
about it and yes typically the party
that retakes the white house will end up
losing the midterms
in the following election
happened to obama it happened to trump
it happened to clinton it happened you
know it happens it happens it happens
historically you're more likely to lose
that first midterm than you are to win
it obviously there are a couple of
exceptions out there
but that's typically what happens so
even just historically
biden and the democrats would be poised
to lose
but this nbc news report says hold up
now folks
it's a little bit more involved than
even just that
first and foremost redistricting is
happening
and because republicans control more
state legislatures than the democrats do
they get to redraw more districts than
the democrats in fact
the number here is astounding let me see
it is uh
republicans get to redraw 187 districts
democrats get to redraw 75.
yeah that's not good that's not good
especially for the party that obviously
has a very strong history of
gerrymandering
i mean if you want to look at what a
gerrymandered district looks like look
no further further than dan crenshaw's
district
you know you got your little almost a
square thing and then you got this big
long loop that curves around in a sea
scooping up all the little republican
areas it's a ridiculously gerrymandered
district
and of course with republicans getting
to redraw more than twice as many as the
democrats
we're going to see more districts that
look like that
and that is unfortunate
and it's something that we can't do a
whole heck of a lot about right now
which i guess just got to sit and watch
it happen and that's terrifying that's a
horrible way to have to look at these
things but that's what it is
second big indicator
that nbc news points out is the money
right
statistically the candidate that raises
the most money has the best chance of
winning
and right now republicans are definitely
out raising democrats they have more
cash on hand than the democratic party
so that's a big advantage for them
another one
that's actually i guess happened after
nbc news had written this article
or they just decided not to include it
for some reason is uh afghanistan
afghanistan is going to play a role in
the 2022 midterms
and because biden was president when all
this chaos happened when the taliban
retook afghanistan
it's gonna fall at his feet and
republicans are going to try to use that
to their advantage
so that is a big hurdle that the
democratic party is going to have to
overcome
and i don't know how they do it
pulling the troops out was the right
decision
the power vacuum created because of that
yes it's the failures of the united
states but it's the failures of 20 years
not just the failures of six months of
joe biden
so
unfair to put it at his feet absolutely
but republicans are going to try to do
that anyway
then of course you have kovit coming
back which again is not joe biden's
fault
but
republicans are going to try to make it
that way as we've talked about donald
trump is already trying to say that joe
biden surrendered to covid
and if kovitt is still around by the
2022 midterms
that's gonna hurt democrats a lot it
really really is especially you know
what's the breakdown in the house now is
what 220 democrats to 212 republicans
another problem democrats have is that
they've got several democrats in swing
districts who are incumbents
who are not running for office or
they're seeking
a senate seat instead
so those districts now become toss-ups
instead of having a strong democratic
incumbent
and
what happens when you have districts
like that where an incumbent does not
run whether it's a republican or
democrat by the way
you have to spend more money
on an unknown than you would on an
incumbent so that race even if you win
it is going to take more resources to be
able to win it
so that's a big drain on the democrats
so how do they fix this
obviously the easy answer you deliver
for the american public
they got the child tax credit going out
right now that's great
you're showing people look we are giving
you money
we're giving you money to help you
through this pandemic
so that's a positive the reconciliation
bill three and a half trillion dollars
depending on whether or not cinema and
mansion shave off some of that that
includes real tangible benefits for
pretty much every single district here
in the united states that is a must-pass
piece of legislation
and honestly i think the midterms are
going to hinge on what happens with that
reconciliation bill
if you make promises to the public as
joe biden did they promise get rid of
some student loan debt they've done a
little
but not in any kind of widespread way
that affects a lot of people
and that's unfortunate that could come
back to bite you
so if you deliver big time with this
reconciliation bill and you give people
something tangible something they can
either hold or see for themselves that
you have done
you just might stave off what could be a
midterm bloodbath
for the democratic party
so that's where it is you know what to
do
so get busy on it
i'm faring cousins in for david pakman
we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow welcome back to the
david pakman show i am fair and cousins
i've been sitting in for david pakman
today
and we've got a lot more to cover and
not a lot of time to do it so let's jump
back in
let's go back to afghanistan actually
where donald trump jr on twitter has
been accused of gloating
over the fact that the taliban has
overtaken this country
in a series of different tweets
trump jr
has either laughed
about what's happening
or
he has directly said well this isn't
surprising and actually gone on to
attack the military itself the u.s
military
here's a sampling of some of these
tweets one of them said not surprising
biden's woke intelligence gurus are the
same ones who were wrong on russia
collusion and russian bounties wrong
about china and iran being competitors
wrong on covet origins wrong on hunter's
laptop and wrong on basically everything
else
hunter's laptop hunter's laptop holy wow
that's something i don't think anybody
has really thought about in a long time
except of course for the grifters who
believe that pushing that idiotic story
uh was gonna do something for him
remember when tucker carlson told us
that he actually you know they had like
the contents of it and he sent it to
himself and then oh it got lost in the
mail oh no
wha what what a non-story that
republicans and again the grifters were
pushing so hard
that just
disappeared
when they realized there was nothing
there and they never made apologies for
it but i guess donald trump jr is still
fuming
about hunter's laptop
what an idiot
not to mention woke intelligence commit
what what what does that what does that
even mean
can anybody explain to me what that
means and how it would have an impact
on
uh the taliban retaking afghanistan
because i'm at a loss for that
i i really cannot connect those two dots
but of course that's republicans today
right
you got to throw the woke people into
every talking point you have whether it
fits or not you just shoehorn it in
there
and people might take you seriously this
is ridiculous
um he goes on in another tweet here and
this was actually in response to
something the u.s embassy in kabul had
uh tweeted out just days ago
calls for peace and he tweeted out lol
this is real
lol laugh out loud
laughing out loud really
we have people
so desperate to flee the country they're
getting run over by airplanes
on the runway at the airport
and this dude's just like lol
what a scumbag
he also attacked the u.s embassy in
kabul where from where officials were
airlifted to safety on sunday for
tweeting in support of lgbt rights in
june because they quote
should have focused on other things but
who knows i'm sure the media will tell
us they're doing great
so he went back and found a tweet from
june
where they're talking about lgbtq
equality he said should have focused on
other things
again all i can say is what a scumbag
what an absolute pathetic piece of human
garbage
but that is what the trump family is
that is what donald j trump jr
is
gloating
about what is happening in the country
of afghanistan even though what's
happening in afghanistan is exactly
what his dad wanted done
your dad junior
wanted us to pull all the troops out of
afghanistan
but of course you know he didn't want it
to happen under his administration so
the deal he signed with the taliban
was oh yeah 14 months from now of course
he expected to be president by then and
if he had one of course this would still
be happening
because this is a failure of 20 years of
policy not seven
months
of joe biden
but hey folks there are a couple bright
spots
and one of the bright spots that we're
seeing in the united states today
is that it appears
that the republican party to a tiny tiny
degree
appears to be warming up to the idea
of renewable energy
there was a great op-ed in the hill this
week
where they actually talked about a piece
of legislation
that republicans are pushing in north
carolina without democratic input but
this piece of legislation
would shut down five major coal-fired
power plants in north carolina in the
coming decade cutting carbon dioxide
emissions and improving air quality
importantly the legislation mandates the
maine north carolina utility duke energy
securitize the cost of coal retirements
that provision will save rate payers
from paying the retirement costs of
those facilities
and is something that could be
replicated in other states across the
country to date only a few other states
have adopted a similar policy the bill
would grow renewable energy
substantially by
4700 megawatts over the next decade
including from solar power and offshore
wind able to power millions of homes
so no north carolina is a purple state
and you get a democratic governor and a
republican-controlled legislature but
this bill was crafted without the input
of democrats
in the state of north carolina
and it actually includes we're going to
close down some coal plants and we're
going to create renewable energy
republicans did it on their own
as somebody who has spent
17 years
covering environmental
news
reporting on it writing it investigating
it
i'm almost in shock folks i am almost
legitimately
in shock
because i never thought we'd see the day
honestly truly 17 years
writing about misinformation on climate
change coming from the right writing
about fossil fuel donations and how
they're paying off politicians
i i'm i'm so incredibly
inspired
by this piece of legislation
and of course we can quibble all day
does it go far enough no probably not
but you know what guys sometimes you got
to take a win as a win
and i'm sick and tired of the all or
nothing types
sometimes even a little progress is
something to be celebrated because you
know what when you celebrate the small
victories and the folks see you out
there congratulating them and applauding
them for doing the small steps do you
know what it encourages them encourages
them to do
take another step
do it again
do more
and sometimes that's what we need to do
more carrot less stick
right so i'm not going to criticize
this piece of legislation right now
if they can get this passed and they can
shut down some of those duke energy
coal-fired power plants in the state of
north carolina then more power to them
replace it with renewable energy that's
even better
this is a good piece of legislation
and i think we need to be celebrating
that fact we get so few victories
especially for the environment folks
so i think we need to celebrate when
that opportunity arises when it presents
itself take advantage of it because
again we don't get a lot of this
and hopefully
other republicans around the country
take note
the issue of climate change has been
partisan here in the united states for
too long but ironically it's actually
not that partisan
when you go out to the voters themselves
majority of republicans support actions
to protect the environment
from the effects of climate change
they support renewable energy as do
obviously huge majorities of democrats
and that's the thing like when you go
out there to the people there's not this
same divide that you see in washington
dc that is not representative of the
actual country
so that's where my hope lies my hope
lies in the people
and i think if we continue to applaud
these steps and more and more people do
that
we might just start getting some good
legislation and of course the
infrastructure bill
right that has investments in renewable
we had some republicans vote to support
it
that's a good thing
renewable energy equals jobs for the
united states you know if you want to
look at it not in terms of environmental
impact if you want to look at it in
dollars and cents it makes perfect sense
and it makes a lot of sense as well
celebrate the victories when you can
folks because again
too few and far between
and finally today
speaking of victories if you can kind of
call it that
the dallas
independent school district
has announced that even though the texas
supreme court ruled over the weekend
that they
cannot
overrun
the governor's ban on mass mandates they
have announced that
we're still going to require people to
wear mass we're leaving our mask mandate
in place
texas supreme court
what are you going to do about it
we're going to protect these kids
we're going to do everything possible
to try to slow the spread or heck even
prevent the spread of covid in our
school district
and so i applaud the dallas independent
school district for doing this and if
you're not familiar with the supreme
court case in the state of texas texas
supreme court over the weekend the texas
supreme court ruled that
the areas of texas that had
basically ignored republican governor
greg abbott's ban on mass mandates
supreme court said hey you can't do that
he has the authority under the texas
emergency act of 1975
he has the authority to do this
because those are his emergency powers
and cove it's an emergency
and to me it's okay if it's an emergency
why aren't we doing everything possible
to protect people
and i think honestly that if the lawyers
had probably had better arguments
and probably weren't going in front of
one of the most right-wing courts in the
country uh this easily would have been a
victory for the districts
texas supreme court
clearly
packed with republicans
so yes of course they're going to roll
with whatever abbott wants them to say
but again it should have been very easy
in a fair district to be able to as the
plaintiffs
point out that the governor's decision
was not based on any health data or
scientific data it was based on partisan
politics and therefore should not be
protected under that 1975 texas
emergency act
any other district or state or court
you're going to win this and we actually
know that because they already wanted in
the lower court
but the texas supreme court said ah it's
not going to fly
but at least the school district is
saying i'm gonna stand up to this
these kids are going to school wearing
masks
this is what it is
what are you gonna do you're gonna
punish us for it punish us
but we're gonna protect these kids
and i applaud them for that
as i mentioned earlier in the program
an eighth grader in mississippi died a
covid last week
440
students and faculty members in broward
county florida i believe it was broward
on quarantine four teachers in broward
county dead from covid last week within
24 hours of one another
coveted outbreaks have shut down five
school districts
in the state of georgia
in the last week
five districts shut down because of
covet outbreaks
and i have no doubt that the dallas
independent school district is looking
around them
and saying
we have to do something we can't allow
ourselves to become what these other
republican-controlled states are
becoming and if we have to defy a court
order to protect these kids then by god
we're going to defy a court order to
protect these kids
so kudos and bravo to the dallas
independent school district for standing
up
for the safety of these children
thank you very much for tuning in today
thank you to david pakman uh you know
this weekend last week allowing me the
time to come on serve as your fill in
host thank to everyone at the staff of
the david pakman show uh patrick you've
been wonderful to work with here and if
you want more from me youtube.com
fairbalance youtube.com slash the ring
of fire twitter facebook and instagram
at farren balanced wonderful bonus show
coming up today for members i'm farron
cousins and thank you for watching the
david
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman